Welcome to the third lesson in Introduction to Data
Science. During this lesson, we're going to be focusing on
some basic methods in statistics and machine learning that you
can use to analyze data. During the last lesson, we
mainly focused on methods to acquire and clean data from
a variety of sources, such as relational databases, APIs, and
flat files. However we also discuss some basic methods that
you can use to verify the integrity of your data.
And while you're doing that you might learn some very
basic things. For example, you might know who the tallest
shortstop to ever play in major league baseball was, or,
how many people over the age of 65 enrolled in the
[INAUDIBLE] program in a particular district. You might find, though,
that you want to answer some more subtle questions. For example,
we might want to know, are left handed batters any
better than right handed batters? Or, hey, is there any correlation
between age and the [UNKNOWN] rejection rate? We'll use
statistics and machine learning to answer these types of questions.
We'll also find that these methods are really useful for
answering questions about ridership on the New York City subway.
For example, we might be able to discover whether
time of day, or the weather outside, influence how many
people are riding the subway. During this lesson, we're going
to assume some basic familiarity with stats. Either you haven't
seen the stuff or if you feel lost, it might be a good idea to
enroll in Stats 95. I've included a link
in the instructor comments. Alright, let's jump in.